so I want you to think about your ninth
grade you're in class the principal you
recognize the voice gets on the intercom
and reads the following statement to
everybody do not use chat GPT or any
other automated writing tool for school
papers this is cheating and will not be
tolerated if you're caught using chat
GPT or any other automated writing tools
for school papers there will be serious
consequences this is an actual statement
that a principal said about Chad GPT
where was Chad GPT when we were in high
school can you imagine some of these
papers by the way in a minute I'm going
to go on the website there's two things
we're going to search on this website
Chachi BT I got a million users in five
days faster than Facebook to come two
years faster than Pinterest it took him
four months faster than Angry Birds took
him 35 days we're gonna test two things
one I'm gonna search write a rap song as
if Tupac would write it two I'm gonna
say I want a paper written on the
Iranian Revolution written by Donald J
Trump's voice let's see what it says
having said that what the hell is Chad
gbt let's learn about it
[Music]
so let's get right into it by the way
just out of curiosity who do you think
is behind this Chad gbt meaning who do
you think started a company in 2015.
what if I told you a guy named Sam
Altman and another guy named Elon Musk
were the co-chairs when they first
started the company and some of the
names of people that committed to giving
a billion dollars to this non-profit
were Peter Thiel Reid Hoffman Jessica
Livingston they brought a CTO from
stripe named Greg Brockman and they
brought the world leading expert in
machine learning on top of that like
it's almost like saying the Justice
League of computer scientists the pro
most Brilliant Minds came together and
saying what can we do to innovate and
Advance open AIS in ways no one's ever
seen before and that's exactly what
they've done so now you may be asking so
Pat what's the big deal about Chad gbt I
mean don't we already have Google what's
the difference between this and Google
it can be better than Google right so
let me give you visualization I actually
go to a library Google is you go in and
say hey I would like to read a book on
the history of the Iranian Revolution no
problem here's a book go read it that's
Google you go to Chad gbt you're going
to say hey can you give me the summary
of what happened in the Iranian
Revolution yes here you go it just gives
it to you here you go do it yourself
here I'm gonna interact with you and by
the way in Google you're talking to a
website in Chad gbt it's as if you're
talking to a human being writing back to
you in a conversational style okay let
me just put it to you this way New York
Times just came out with an article
saying this is a code red for Google and
Elon Musk said in a tweet this is scary
good we're not far from dangerously
strong AI so let me kind of give you an
example I'm going to go on the website
right now like I promised you earlier
let's let's see what happens if I type
in write a song like Tupac let's see
what it says okay by the way just so you
know the website's already crashed while
I'm searching it it already crashed it's
constantly crashing you can read about
this so now write a song like Tupac
let's see what it says it's doing it for
me right now here's a sample Tupac
inspired song keep in mind that I'm a
huge language model and do not have
personal experience or feelings or so my
lyrics not capture the same emotion or
depth as Tupac's work now verse one
I was born in the gutter raising the
streets mama was a hustler Daddy was
deceased I had to fend for myself no
time to sleep the only way to survive
was to stay on my feet I'm a warrior I
Won't Back Down a [ __ ] for what I
believe won't let them push me around
I'm a soldier I won't give in I'll Stand
Tall even when it feels like the world
is caving in this is insane by the way
that this this has happened in real time
right now I've seen the worst that life
has to offer but I won't let it bring me
down I'll rise up and prosper I've been
knocked down but I won't stay on the
ground I'll get back up and I I'll wear
a crown I'm a warrior I want back then
and it keeps going back to it it's doing
it right now by the way this is still
going it's still going by itself it's
writing the song in a mill how crazy is
this Mario okay let me do another one
here for you write a paper on Iran
revolution
revolution and make it sound like Donald
Trump
the Iranian Revolution was a huge deal
folks
it was a time of great upheaval on
turmoil in the Middle Eastern country of
Iran the Revolution was led by
telecomeni who was a very dishonest and
corrupt man
he was supported by many radical Islamic
groups and they were all determined to
destroy the great and peaceful country
of Iran under the leadership of Khomeini
the Iranian people were subjected to all
sorts of Horrors this is it's still
going it's still writing it I mean what
are you going to write a paper for FYI
you know what's happening the whole
thing with the principles and you cannot
use this anymore so teachers are
starting to realize that kids are using
chat gbt there's a website called quill
bot which you'll go here and get the
paper then you take it from there put it
on coolbot and kobot makes it seem like
you wrote it so the school cannot track
it and then you submit it and the
teacher has to believe that you wrote it
or somebody else wrote it but they can't
track it I mean do you realize how big
of a disruption this is for copywriters
for schools for teachers for professors
how are you going to know now to kind of
get things to be more real life you have
to write the paper in class to believe
that the person wrote it not a website
wrote it anyways this is the website and
what it's doing that's revolutionizing
many different Industries however were
they the first to do this did anybody
else do this on what happened to him
what if I told you both Microsoft and
meta try to do this and they both flop
for different reasons Microsoft did it
with a company called Tay for 24 hours
this was like in 2015 or 2016. and it
was all AI you know generated content
that's coming up and it's doing it
itself until all of a sudden the tweets
went from being a good human being to
being a white supremacist literally
calling out feminists within 24 hours
that project was over with for Microsoft
and Mena had a similar type of website
called blenderbot 3 but they had a
challenge because a user asked the
question about who won the election and
blenderbot 3 claimed that Donald Trump
won the election obviously it was over
from there but now Chad gbt what they've
done the last few weeks has gone from 0
to 29 billion dollars in valuation so
they're the ones so far that have been
able to get it right the most doesn't
mean they're not going to have any
glitches but so far so good in the first
few weeks so what does this mean to
everybody to you to me to the consumer
it's just another cool tool to use but
to people involved in spaces like
technology copywriting they're going to
experience a lot of disruption so that
could be leading to unemployment or it
could lead to millions of new jobs being
created just like nobody thought some of
these websites were being created oh my
God that thing's going to eliminate so
many jobs no Google Creator jobs YouTube
created jobs radina they create a many
different unique ways of making money so
advancement Innovation coming at a very
very fast pace and by the way this may
not be the brick phone but it could be
the Nokia phone okay that we're talking
about with advancement this is
definitely not at the level of the
smartphone or the iPhone so it's going
to be very interesting where this AI
goes to we're definitely going into
Uncharted territories that we've not
been in which means get used to having
to adapt and learn very very quickly and
having to see things that we've never
been used to before that can disrupt
many different Industries or help you
grow your business to the next level
having said that I got another video I
want you to watch I want to get your
thoughts on chat gbt comment below I'll
be reading your comments but also
another video I want you to watch
2023 predictions what I'm calling 2023
the year of if you've not seen that
video click here to watch the video take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]